yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jan and
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into the third season of stranger
things the Easter eggs you might have
missed and the crucial details on the
ending and post-credit scenes that set
things up for season four Plus and
explain exactly how the show tricked you
about hoppy
in the finale I've got a stranger things
giveaway on this video so subscribe hit
the bell and let me know about what you
thought of the new season for a chance
to win obviously spoilers ahead so take
care if you're not all caught up
unlike season two were a lab enclosed
the gate and cut the mine flour off from
the demo dogs this time al has lost her
powers for the moment so it's up to
Joyce and Harper to get to the gate and
destroy the machine that's keeping it
open as they try to turn the Machine off
hopper is attacked by the Terminator
like Russian although Hopf manages to
push the goon into the spinning machine
time is running out to save the day so
he nods to Joyce signaling that she has
to shut the Machine down herself even
though he's standing right next to it
which puts him in great danger as the
Machine explodes some nearby Russian
scientists disintegrate the gate closes
and the connection between the mind
flayer behind the gate and its monster
inside the mall is broken killing the
Beast now if you're upset that Hopper
was killed in the explosion there are
plenty of clues to suggest that's not
the case first of all after Joyce turned
the keys to shut down the machine the
screen conveniently cut to black
suggesting at least a few seconds of
time passed and that something happened
off screen and as Joyce turns those keys
she looks down and away from the
platform presumably because she can't
bear to see what she thinks will happen
to hopper in reality though it means
that she wouldn't have seen hopper leave
the platform because in the next shot as
we watched the spinning machine go out
of control and explode if you look
really closely at the platform where
Hopper was standing you'll see there's
nobody there anymore so where did he go
and why hasn't anyone heard from him
well there are a few possibilities
including one that the show hints at in
the mid credit scene at the end of the
season in this bonus scene we discover
that the Russians are feeding human
prisoners to a Dever Gorgon but more
crucially we find out that they've got
an American prisoner in one of their
cells
if Hopper got off the platform before
the explosion and escaped into the
nearby room that Joyce Marie
ran into later it's quite possible that
he bumped into a group of Russians who
apprehended him and hauled him off to
Russia another theory is that Hoffa
didn't have time to find a safe exit
before the machine exploded in the gate
closed
so rather than stick around and risk
being fried he jumped through the gate
and is now stuck in the upside-down
three inch minimum we put three inches
perhaps that's what the show is hinting
at when it shows hop turn and look at
the gate before it closes and don't
forget that hopper has been in the
upside down before to look for will with
Joyce if he is now on the other side
there's no immediate way out for him
unless he can find a breach back to our
world like L did at the start of season
2 a twist on this idea is that sometime
after Hopper jumped over to the other
dimension
the Russians figured out how to open up
their own connection to the upside down
at their base in Russia and he emerges
through there which is how he's ended up
in their cell an alternative theory is
the machine that the Russians developed
has some similarities to a particle
accelerator and that when it blew up in
Hawkins it caused a rift in time and
space
sending hopper backwards in time to the
same location for example a year ago at
which point he was captured by the
Russians the penultimate episode did
have some heavy back to the future
references so perhaps that's what they
were hinting at the other big clue that
hopper survived is that the song heroes
plays while L is reading hops heart to
heart letter that same song played in
the first season when will Baez dead
body was discovered and as we all know
wills death proved to have been a fake
and he's still clearly alive and
remember hoppers adopted daughter L also
seemed to die at the end of season 1
disintegrating as she took out the
demagoguing so there's definitely hope
for hope now although I'm convinced
Hopper is still alive somewhere there
are some alternative possibilities for
who the mysterious American is inside
the Russian cell another character who's
been heavily suggested to still be alive
is dr. Brenner
aka Elevens popper although Brenner was
mauled by the demo Gorgon in season 1
when L and her sister Karli visited one
of his ex-colleagues in the second
season he claimed that Brenner was still
alive Brunner
I can take you to him Papa is gone
no he is a why if Ray knew where Brenna
was it's quite possible that the
Russians track down the former director
of the Hawkins lab to take him captive
and help them open a gate to the upside
down another possibility is that one of
eleven siblings from the Rainbow Room is
locked in the cell but it's also
possible that the unnamed American in
the cell is an entirely new character
being introduced for season four the
other big revelation from the
post-credits scene is that the Russians
are now in control of a demo Gorgon
which could mean a couple of things they
may have discovered the demagogue
enduring their time in Hawkins as we saw
they had extra tall cages and electric
cattle prods which were presumably for
containing the monsters or it might be
proof that the Russians have now managed
to open their own gate to the upside
down in Russia just as we saw them
trying to do in the opening scene of
season 3 we can't discuss the finale of
season 3 of course without discussing
Billy and the mind flayers new monster
after the mine fly was driven out of
wills body in season 2 the black
particles weren't destroyed entirely and
season 3 reveals that they ended up at
the abandoned steelworks building
outside Hawkins
when the Russians open up the gate to
the upside down in their base below star
court mall those black particles are
reactivated in fact whilst Ranger sense
or will tingle is triggered when he
feels the monsters presence again after
a swarm of nearby rats run past him and
into the brim borm steelworks building
the mind flayer now begins to slowly
build a new body for itself starting
with these rats which burst open and
combined to form a new monster the mind
flare then causes Billy to crash his car
using the opportunity to possess him and
use him not only as a human spying
Hawkins like the big bad did with will
in season 2 but also to gather human
victims I wanted to build
to build what what you see the possessed
Billy starts with his lifeguard
colleague Heather and the pair then move
on to her parents by the sixth episode
Billy has amassed around 30 people who
are now called the flayed as they act
like normal people until the mind flayer
activates them at this point they all
converged the steelworks building where
they melt down into a mess of bones and
flesh and join the body of the monster
which grows bigger with each new body it
absorbs and this is the meaning of the
Latin title of the episode a pluribus
unum which translates as out of many one
and fits with this season's 4th of July
Independence Day setting as that phrase
is also the original motto of the United
States before they join with the monster
though the flayed humans and rats will
often consume toxic amounts of
fertilizer and chemicals it may be that
the monster feeds off and grows bigger
from these chemicals but the consumption
of these is also so that the human or
animal body is physically weakened and
will easily melt and break down making
this probably the grossest monster on
the show so far as the mind flayers
humans 5 for locating 11 Billy's kept
alive until the finale where he's able
to pin down alan the mall after she
loses her powers billy's about to offer
11 to the monster but she helps him
regain control of his mind when she
connects with him and reminds him of his
childhood with his mother
Billy's self-sacrifice as he stands up
to the monster to stop it from getting
to 11 gives him a nice Redemption arc
and in this case unlike with hopper we
did see his dead body so I don't think
he'll be coming back to Hawkins unless
it's in flashbacks by 11 or his
stepsister mags cover-ups of what's
really been going on in Hawkins continue
with the general population still
seemingly unaware of the secret Russian
installation in the town or the fact
that it was the mind flayers monster
which was responsible for destroying the
star court mall on the 4th of July the
cutting edge expose that runs on TV
three months later focuses blame for the
mysterious goings-on and missing people
on a corrupt mur and local government
chemical leaks and the program even
suggests that Satanism may be a fault
and links that to playing Dungeons &
Dragons some believe a rise in
is to blame to find out tune in tonight
at 8:00 p.m. for horror in the heartland
which is incredibly something that some
groups have complained about in reality
the TV documentary reminds me of how
back in season two Murray told Nancy and
Jonathan that to reveal what had
happened to barb they needed to water
down their story to make it more
palatable to the general public
perhaps Barbara was exposed to some
dangerous toxins a leak from the lab
like Three Mile Island or something
something scary but familiar
interestingly enough season three secret
russian invasion was partially predicted
by Murray himself right at the beginning
of season two I believe there was and
may very well still be a Russian spy
presence in hak5 I'm talking a full-on
Russian invasion right here in Harkins
Murray might have been wrong about
eleven being one of those Russians but
when dr. Owens arrives at the end of
season three and discovers what's
happened he might be thinking back to
this conversation he had with Nancy and
Jonathan in season two but imagine for a
moment if a foreign state let's say the
Soviets if they heard about our mistake
do you think they would even consider
that a mistake what if they try to
replicate that after all that's gone on
I wonder of season three you will also
find Murray relocating as he did say
that hopper and Joyce had compromised
his secure hideaway since the end of
season 2 when the mindflow is shown
watching over Hawkins school as the
ultra creepy song every breath you take
played it's been hinted that the shadowy
monster has had his eye on 11:00 and
indeed she did turn out to be his
ultimate target this season presumably
in revenge for her closing the gate in
season two and foiling the demo Gorgon
in season one and also because it sees
her as the main threat to its larger
plan for domination of our world after
the monster bit eleven and infected her
leg it seems the mind flare may have at
least temporarily weakened al depowering
her for the final episode this worked as
a convenient plot device to avoid a
repeat of the season two finale where
eleven did all the work of closing the
gate but it also means that L can't
search for hopper to confer
he's really gone or not Mike is
confident that Elevens powers will
return and I expect this will be an
important part of her arc in season 4
the season ends with Joyce will and
Jonathan moving away from Hawkins taking
11 with them this splits up the gang
however Mike mentions meeting up around
Thanksgiving in Christmas
I suspect that rather than season 4
taking place during the 1985 winter
holidays it'll be set around a year and
a half after the events of season 3
putting it towards the end of 1986 which
will roughly keep it in line with how
the young actors are growing up
off-screen and I wonder if Dustin will
try and invite his girlfriend Susie over
for another rendition of the neverending
story or if she could even travel from
Utah to join them on their next
adventure
oh and assuming hopper does return next
season I wonder if he'll be rocking his
full-on Tom Selleck as magnum p.i look
again that's a lot of color for you
chief it's cutting edge after all I
think hops love of Magnum isn't just
about what he calls the characters
cutting-edge look but also about the
fact that they're both veterans of
Vietnam one thing missing from season
three was any continuing story about
Carly who al met last season but if dr.
Branagh does come back into play next
season we could see Carly or the other
gifted children from Hawkins lab
reappear you can learn more about them
and the dark history of Brenner's
MKULTRA experiments in my stranger
things gifted children video tap the
link here or check the link in the video
description now what are your opinions
and theories about season 3 and how do
you think hopper survived the explosion
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe to
enter my stranger things giveaway next
tapleft that stranger things theory
video or tap write for another video
you're sure to LIKE and if you enjoyed
this a like share and subscribe a hugely
appreciated thanks for watching and see
you next time yippie guy move you lovers